today on the matt walsh show the u.s
birth rate is collapsing our
civilization is going extinct some may
consider that a minor problem others say
it's actually a good thing we'll discuss
also joe biden finally answers some
questions about his afghanistan
evacuation plan and his answers were
more unintelligible than usual he is
falling apart before our eyes as the
world also falls apart great stuff
meanwhile the left continues to argue
that the taliban in afghanistan
really aren't any worse than
conservatives here in america and this
line of argument raises a few questions
which i will ask today and a doctor in
alabama announces that he will not see
any patients who haven't been vaccinated
while another doctor elsewhere in the
country takes a picture of himself
crying on the job and posts it to
twitter to raise awareness about the
fact that he's an attention starved
drama queen we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matt wall show
and now we will check in with our good
friends over at moynk we uh at my house
we recently got our latest moiq shipment
and um we've i would like to say that we
you know were able to space it out and
everything but we really we tear through
that thing pretty quickly and so we've
already finished it off moich delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
wild-caught alaskan salmon
directly to your door they've also got
bacon i should mention very very very
good bacon all of their stuff is great
and not only are they sending you great
food but they're helping family farms
become financially independent outside
of big agriculture their animals are
raised outdoors their fish swim wild in
the ocean and moink meat is free of
antibiotics hormones sugar none of that
junk you're getting with the prepackaged
stuff
so it's delicious it's healthy for you
and you can sign up at mointbox.comwalsh
right now to get speaking of their bacon
a year of bacon for free and then pick
what meats you want delivered with your
first box cannot recommend this enough
so join the movement today go to
mointbox.comwalsh right now and
listeners to the show get free bacon for
a year again that is free bacon for a
year that's one year of the best bacon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
so you want to go to moicbox.com walsh
spelled m o i n k box dot com slash
walsh
so this uh may or may not seem like a
big deal to you but it's probably at
least worth mentioning that we are going
extinct
as a civilization it is you might say a
minor problem u.s birth rates are
dropping like iraq and have been for
some time a report a few months ago
found that the birth rate in the united
states fell again in 2020 a four percent
decline from 2019 and 2019 had been a
decline from the year before that and so
on as it stands right now the fertility
rate is 56 births per 1000 women that's
the general
fertility rate which is the lowest we've
ever seen
in a given year
the completed fertility rate or total
fertility rate which tells us how many
children a woman will have in her
lifetime is now at 1.6 also the lowest
ever and well below replacement level in
fact we haven't had a fertility rate
above replacement level since the early
70s at least after years of hysteria
over the mythological beast known as
overpopulation we're now being told that
our problem is exactly the opposite a
headline on cnbc says that researchers
are now warning of under population
instead instead of having so many people
packed onto the earth that islands are
capsizing on themselves as a democrat
congressman once famously worried about
out loud uh now instead we face the much
more real problems of living in a
society where families aren't producing
enough children to replace themselves
the average number of children per
family is now under two
people still talk about it like it's uh
you know the standard 2.5 kids per
family it's actually like 1.7 now and
it's been under two for a long time
much is being written um
about why this is happening but but the
reasons reasons should be clear enough
yes we are experiencing record levels of
infertility that's that's
one reason
a great boon for the ivf industry but
not so great in any other sense
why all of the infertility well it could
have something to do with the chemicals
we're consuming uh there could be plenty
of diet and environmental factors i'm
sure that that that weighs in here
that's part of the problem
and it's also a fact that women are
choosing to wait until they are past
their peak fertility years to start
having kids
the average age for having a first child
and and only child much of the time is
now 26 or 27 for women and around 30 for
men or older
26 is still within peak fertility range
but to get to that average
you know not too long ago it was like 20
or 21. a few decades ago
so to get to the 26 average there have
to be of course millions of women
waiting until they're well into their
30s to even start
in fact in many other countries across
the west in europe
the average age the average age for
women to start families is 30
meaning that women are on average
waiting until their fertility starts to
wane to even start a family or try
now this again is great news for ivf
clinics
bad news for everybody else or is it bad
news if you listen to the media
well you're not going to hear a whole
lot about this issue at all but when you
do hear about it
very often you'll be told that the
collapse of the american birth rate and
our plummeting fertility levels are not
a big deal at all an article this past
weekend in the atlantic written by
elizabeth brunig says that the
population decline narrative is nothing
but a right-wing trope now it's just
something that right-wingers talk about
she says that most women do end up
having kids eventually so why does it
matter
a piece recently published in popular
science goes a step further explaining
that our march towards extinction is
good actually the writer argues that
this is all a reflection of shifting
gender roles and the fact that more
women are working and so it's something
to celebrate besides kids are expensive
and also the article says we can just
bring immigrants in to replace us and
pick up the slack
only don't call it replacement because
as we've seen that makes you a white
supremacist unless you're writing for
popular science in which case you know
you can you can acknowledge the
replacement as long as you think it's
good
that's the rule
somehow though even after reflecting on
these compelling arguments
i still can't see our population decline
as anything but bad news
i mean very very bad news
crisis level bad news
and two reasons are worth considering
here
the first is the rather obvious but
crucial point that the human race
requires humans in order to exist
and i for one consider existence to be a
superior state to non-existence
i prefer existence i don't know about
you i prefer a future over no future
these are just my own preferences
admittedly but even so
i mean we can look
historically and see that a rapid
decline in birth rates has never been a
good sign for any civilization this is
always something that precedes collapse
no civilization has given up on future
generations
and seen the birth rate plummet and then
went on to flourish because of it
that's never happened and we're not
going to be the exception
but you know there's something else too
it's a different problem but related
the other issue with our birth rate
decline
is that it reveals a dramatic and
ultimately cataclysmic shift in our
priorities as a people
as much as we may want to blame external
factors
we can't afford kids they're expensive
it's not feasible whatever
the fact is that we are having fewer
kids or no kids
because we have prioritized our time and
money in other ways
it should already be obvious that the
money excuse is pretty lame
considering the fact that the average
american family 200 years ago was
exponentially larger than ours and
exponentially poorer
no it can't be a lack of money or
resources but rather how we choose to
expend them
in fact it's hard to say that our choice
to forgo parenthood is a matter of
prudent financial planning when we're
spending almost a hundred billion
dollars a year on our pets
that's billion with a b
go look it up
over the course of this decade if the
rates stay the same and don't increase
which they will but pretending they
don't
we will have spent a trillion dollars
taking care of our favorite four-legged
creatures a trillion
while complaining that we just don't we
don't have the money for kids right now
and that's to say nothing of all the
money we spend on consumer electronics
and other luxuries we have the funds to
start families we just don't have the
priorities
a a civilization that
gives up
on the future is an inherently
self-centered and shallow civilization
and that's maybe the worst consequence
of our declining birth rates
though you might say that it's
both the cause and the consequences both
the chicken and the egg
as we forfeit family life
we begin to live lives that are
increasingly focused only on the here
and now and only on finding personal
comfort and enjoyment in the here and
now a civilization that produces lots of
children and large families also
produces better people less selfish
people people who who feel called to
dedicate themselves to a cause bigger
than their own entertainment
they care more about their country
more about the civilization they are a
part of
this is also part of the story when we
see the decline in patriotism
why are people less patriotic now
well because they're less invested in
their country
they care less about it
they're less connected to it
when you have a family it's a different
story
also when you're having kids and you
have a family you know you're you're
happier and more joyful i mean
ultimately
living in a country which has chosen
population decline embraced it as a
lifestyle choice chosen it
the worst thing about it is the despair
now people may be entertained they may
be satiated they may be comfortable they
may be well fed and fat and we are
certainly all of those things
and we have we may have more funds
available for vacations and to buy the
newest iphone when it releases but
we're also going to be in despair
because we see no deeper purpose in life
and we're not concerned about the future
a declining civilization is a despairing
civilization you wonder why everybody's
depressed and anxious and they're going
to their therapists and psychiatrists
asking for pills
to solve the problem
and yet they find
more often than not the pill doesn't
solve the problem
to give up on having babies is to give
up on having hope it's to give up on
purpose
and you know there are some people a
small minority who have embraced this
truth
they call themselves anti-natalists and
they will openly profess that the human
race has a net negative value
that life itself is meaningless and
without purpose and our ultimate hope
and destiny is in our own collective
oblivion
most people who choose childish
childlessness and childishness uh have
not thought about it on a philosophical
level like that and so they don't really
identify themselves with the
anti-natalist movement
but this is their view whether they
fully acknowledge it or not or even
whether they fully realize it or not one
of the early philosophers of the
anti-natalist movement was a guy named
peter wessel zapfa who you've never
heard of because almost nobody has heard
of him especially in america
he wrote an essay i think he only wrote
one thing that was ever translated into
english and it's an essay that was very
influential in certain circles
it was called the last messiah and in it
he unveils his vision of a society
that
finally chooses to embrace its own
extinction
he believed that life is meaningless
that the future is meaningless
that the existence of human beings was
nothing but a tragic accident
that it is morally wrong to have kids
and to bring them into this into this
meaningless purposeless
life
and at the end of this thoroughly
depressing essay which i did read
he imagines the last messiah the true
messiah
showing up to preach his saving gospel
of extinction here's what he writes
he says
then we'll appear the man who as the
first of all has dared strip his soul
naked and submitted alive to the outmost
thought of the lineage the very idea of
doom a man who has fathomed life in its
cosmic ground and whose pain is the
earth's collective pain with what
furious scream shall not mobs of all
nations cry out for his thousand-fold
death when like a cloth his voice
encloses the globe and the strange
message has resounded for the first and
last time
and he says
the life of the world is a roaring river
but earth's is a pond and a backwater
the sign of doom is written on your
brows how long will ye kick against the
pinpricks but there is one conquest and
one crown one redemption and one
solution
know yourselves
be infertile and let the earth be silent
after you
now this is in fact the conquest and
crown that our civilization has chosen
chosen
infertility
to let the earth be silent after us
if it sounds awful and depressing and
appalling
well then the good news is you're still
sane
what should you do about it
well get married have babies
pretty simple really have lots of babies
be fruitful and multiply
the very first command god gives us in
scripture
and there's a reason why it was first as
it turns out
let's get now to our five headlines
we've talked about it a lot on this show
there are a lot of jobs available right
now uh which should be good news for
everybody but unfortunately a lot of
employers are having some serious
trouble finding people finding the right
candidates for the job but according to
forbes gyms nail salons hotels mama pop
stores and more are set to go on an epic
hiring spree in the coming months to
meet the pent-up demand for all of these
services all these businesses reopening
means that millions of jobs will need to
be filled and do need to be filled right
now so where do these businesses turn to
fill those roles well they go to zip
recruiter or they should if they know
what's good for them right now you could
try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
walsh when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send your job to over 100
top job sites giving you access to their
network of millions of job seekers uh
zip recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and proactively presents
them
to you so this is a proactive thing it's
not a passive thing where you're just
putting it out there and waiting for the
result they're going to go and find you
those candidates zip recruiters
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day so right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com walsh
that's ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h just go to zip recruiter dot
com
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
all right afghanistan let's talk about
afghanistan i hope you'll forgive me for
not beginning the show with afghanistan
there are there are other things
in the world that are that are happening
that are important like again the
extinction of our civilization kind of
an important thing
um but afghanistan is also happening so
we're going to go through some of this
this isn't even going to really be five
headlines this is just a jumble this is
a ball oh headlines is what it's really
going to be it's got a bunch of things
to cover here we'll start i guess with
joe biden you've probably seen some of
these clips but worth playing again he
was interviewed by george
uh snuffalophagus on abc
and this is the first time that joe
biden has taken any questions on
afghanistan these are the only questions
he has not given a single press
conference about it
or he's given things that look like
press conferences but then he shuffles
away
uh before you know answering any
questions about it so he sits down here
and he he
to to allegedly answer some questions
but what he has to say is
we are used to hearing unintelligible
things from this man
but this is far worse than you would
even expect let's listen
when you look at what's happened over
the last week was it a failure of
intelligence planning
execution or judgment
look i don't think it was a fail look it
was a simple choice george
when the when the taliban
let me back and put another way when you
had
the government of afghanistan
the leader of that government getting a
plane and taking off and going another
country
when you saw
the significant collapse of the top of
the afghan troops we had trained or up
to 300 000 of them just leaving their
equipment and and taking off
that was you know i'm not this is that
that's what happened that's simply what
happened but we've all seen the pictures
we've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen
afghans fall was four days ago five days
ago what did you think when you first
saw those pictures well i thought was
weird we have to gain control of this we
have to move this more quickly we have
to move in a way in which we can take
control that airport
and we did
so you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow there's a
way to have gotten out without chaos
ensuing i don't know how that happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
the only thing
that was honest and made sense
of all those clips you just heard was
where you said i don't know how that
happened
i believe him on that he doesn't know
how anything happened
the process by which he ended up sitting
in that chair talking to the abc
reporter he's not he doesn't know how
that happened either
it is not an exaggeration to say this
man
literally cannot complete a sentence
i mean am i wrong was there one full
sentence uttered
he starts to begin a sentence and then
kind of trails off and cuts himself off
and then goes off in another direction
some of this is that he's scrambling to
come up with excuses and he's panicking
um but then a lot of it is also that
he's 78 years old and he has dementia
turns out
that having a dementia adult
alzheimer's patient for a president is
not a good idea who would have thought
turns out it's not a good idea
let's can we agree to not ever do this
again the thing is we can't agree even
after this experience
we as a people are so collectively
stupid that we can't even agree like can
we agree that we're never going to have
another 78 year old president ever again
we're not going to try this experiment
again
we can't
um
he says he says
it's hard to really analyze what he said
because again there was
almost nothing coherent there except
when he would accept when he confessed
that he has no idea what's going on
uh the bit about how it was four or five
days ago when people were falling off of
airplanes
i i i'm not sure what he was actually
going for there what what point was he
trying to make
and of course he's got his friend
interviewing him and he's so he's not
going to follow up he's not he's he's
doing every the the reporter
uh stefanopo stefo uh snuffalock
snuffleupagus whatever his name is
he's doing everything he can
to help joe but he's asking questions
but he's doing it he's not gonna follow
up on a question
where the answer was that embarrassing
that was four or five days ago yeah and
what's your point
first of all it wasn't four or five days
ago when he gave that answer
i can't imagine joe biden
if he was ever accused of murder
and he's sitting down during the
interrogation did you murder that person
[ __ ] that was four or five days ago what
does it matter
there are points you could make about
the fact that people were falling off of
the airplane
now i understand that the visual is
obviously very upsetting
for anybody
and politically of course it's also
disastrous for the biden administration
and for good reason because as everyone
agrees the whole this whole thing has
been handled disastrously
um but also you you could point out that
um
[Music]
you know people chose to sit on the
outside of an airplane that was about to
take off into the sky
and it's it's also very likely that the
person flying the plane didn't know that
you don't exactly have rear view mirrors
that are going to show you that so he
did so the the person flying the plane
let's not put the blame on them for this
they're trying to get out and they're
being swabbed swamped by a mob of people
and so they're worried that this mob is
gonna is gonna stop everybody from
getting out
they've got like 600 people inside that
plane most of them young men
so they're trying to get out they didn't
realize that there was anyone sitting on
the outside of the plane i think it
would have been reasonable for them to
assume that nobody would do that because
that's suicidal there's like zero chance
of that resulting in anything but your
immediate death
um so
you know i i think that's a point that
joe biden if he was cognizant
could make
um
he could say listen it's a horrible
thing it's very very sad we can't blame
the people on the ground for that
um that would be fine but he's not
capable of saying that
instead the move from biden and biden's
administration his handlers is to try to
change the subject
let's not talk about
the taliban let's not talk about what's
happening in afghanistan let us redirect
and find enemies here at home
find find someone else to be angry about
because if americans are angry about the
taliban
then that means that they're going to be
putting it on the administration so
let's try to switch this up and that's
why joe biden yesterday gave a speech
where he didn't talk about afghanistan
at all even though it's the only thing
that anybody is is thinking about right
now
uh instead he wanted to talk about mask
mandates
and he found a new enemy
those are the people who are against
mask mandates and specifically the
people in tennessee
we are the real enemies here as joe
biden explains
unfortunately
as you've seen throughout this pandemic
some politicians are trying to turn
public safety measures that is children
wearing masks in school into political
disputes
for their own political gain
some are even trying to take power away
from local educators by banning mass in
school
they're setting a dangerous tone
for example
last week at a school board meeting in
tennessee
protesters threatened doctors and nurses
who were testifying making the case
for masking children in schools
intimidation and the threats we're
seeing across the country are wrong
they're unacceptable
so he's that this is what the the meth
this is the the plan here is to redirect
and let's talk about people who are
against mass mandates
and all of them now are villains and
they want children to get sick
we see this same method as always
remember
it wasn't all that long ago
well it wasn't all that long ago when of
course nobody was masking kids
no one was even considering masking kids
once again flu season
much more dangerous to kids nobody
considered it it wasn't put on the table
it was not even
something that was discussed by anybody
and then with covid it becomes for a
while a live issue should we mask kids
and there were people on either side of
it and the so-called public health
authorities we're on either side of it
in fact there are still some of our
blessed sacred public health authorities
who say you shouldn't put masks on kids
before the age of say five
um
and you could kind of be it was a debate
you could be on either side of it
and now debate is over
you the the only acceptable position is
to be in favor of forcing kids to wear
masks
uh for eight hours a day
as young as three or four years old you
know preschool age
that's that is always the trajectory
so you take a point of view and opinion
that at first
nobody agrees with everyone would say is
absurd
so absurd that we didn't even talk about
it
and then for and then for a brief period
of time because once the ruling class
once the elites decide
that this is a this is an opinion we
should all have there's going to be a
brief period of time
where allegedly it's up for debate and
we pretend that we're debating it
and we're looking at the science and
we're weighing pros and cons
but the outcome has already been decided
because very quickly we're going to
transition through that period to nope
it's been decided debate is over you
have to agree with us on this
this opinion that nobody agreed with uh
18 months ago now you you have to and if
you don't then you are a genocidal
murderous maniac and you want to kill
kids
and you are the real enemy says
joe biden
that's what we need to be talking about
our enemies here at home
certainly not the taliban
and our enemies here at home are just
people that
people like me and you
this in fact has been a message that
we've we've heard from the left a lot
over the last few days sometimes
disguised as a joke here's stephen
colbert who has yet to to make a single
funny joke at any point during his late
night show his comedy central show where
where all he did was make fun of
conservatives was was actually funny
sometimes
um but
i'm not aware maybe someone could point
me to it i'm not aware for the years
that he's been doing this thing on cbs
i'm not aware of him ever having one
funny joke or segment or bit or anything
and he certainly didn't start he didn't
end that streak with this let's listen
we've had troops there for 20 years
they fought
they sacrificed their families
sacrificed so that we wouldn't have a
terrorist attack
in america planned in a foreign country
why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill
yeah
the way that they're leaning into that
comparison
this this is what the left always does
of course because they're never on the
defense
they're just going to lean into it
michael moore
had the same thing he said their taliban
our taliban everybody's got a taliban
they're at their best when they
confiscate the halls of power and then
we've got a picture of the taliban up
there and then a picture of uh
the guy in the bison
suit and the the the you know the horn
hat walking through the capitol
you know you notice some differences
though
like the people at
top at the top there the taliban
they all have guns for one thing they're
armed
and then the bottom picture no guns no
one's armed
they're armed with flags and a bull horn
and a hat with horns on it
this is a comparison
that should embarrass them
because for months they've been saying
oh it's a it was an insurrection of
violent insurrection our way of life was
threatened
and now with the taliban you see what a
violent insurrection actually is you see
what it what it really means what it
really entails
when a violent group of extremists take
over the government
okay you've got the president of the
country fleeing in a helicopter
the military laying down their arms
surrendering sometimes
sometimes joining the other side
now you have armed men who have taken
control of the government
killing people in the
streets even if the media is not quite
highlighting some of that stuff
that's what an insurrection looks like
what you're seeing in afghanistan right
now that's what an interaction looks
like
uh
compare that to what happened on capitol
hill on january 6th
where you had a bunch of unarmed people
walking into the capitol building
which which in many cases the the the
doors were opened for them by the
capitol police they walk in
take some selfies put their put their
feet up on nancy pelosi's desk someone
steals a lectern
and then they leave
that comparison reveals just how vapid
and ridiculous
the insurrection claim really is
but rather than the left being
embarrassed by that
they lean into it and they say yep you
see exactly the same
and we've seen more of these kinds of
comparisons msnbc just published an
editorial which says over the last few
days the airwaves have been filled with
republicans
voicing their deep concern over the
rights of the women of afghanistan house
minority leader kevin mccarthy put out a
statement sounding alarm bells that
women will suffer the most from the loss
of human rights under the taliban's rule
representative stephen chabot the
self-described dean of ohio gop
congressional delegation appeared sunday
on npr declaring that under taliban rule
the lives of women and girls are going
to be reduced condemned to slavery
and yet the writer goes on
i have to wonder where these voices are
when extremists based on a narrow
reading of their religion's beliefs
enacted a law that forces a woman who
was raped to carry the fetus of the
rapist to term
the same law makes it a crime for anyone
to assist that woman in trying to abort
the rapist fetus and then it goes on
from there drawing the expected
comparison between pro-lifers and the
taliban
uh and mark lamont hill
i'm
it's hard this is a this is a we had a
little bit of a joe biden problem here
where it's hard to tell what exactly
he's trying to
say but he had his uh his his show on
black news tonight
and
he was
trying to explain
i think maybe i'll play this and you
tell me what he's trying to say it
sounds like he's trying to blame white
conservatives
for the fact that women in afghanistan
have to wear burqas
i don't know let's listen
this is about the way in which the hijab
is being used as a political tool
first to demonize islam
to make islam look more oppressive and
repressive than any other
religion or culture in the world
it's also being used as a tool to
justify american imperialism
there has been a consistent narrative
from the west particularly these united
states since 9 11 to suggest that the
reason we're invading countries the
reason we're plundering the reason we're
bombing the reason we're exploiting is
to save the women look at what they have
to wear on their heads they have no
agency they have no freedom and we're
going to fix that right now one is
dishonest and disingenuous because there
are women in saudi arabia who are being
exploited there women in saudi arabia
who are being denied human rights and we
say nothing why because we want oil and
weapons but somehow when it comes to
afghanistan we suddenly get uh outraged
we suddenly have morals and ethics
america doesn't have feelings it has
interest and right now it has an
interest in making you believe that
their imperial theft and plunder is part
of an attempt of white men to save brown
women from brown men and it's all a
complete
lie do not buy into the theatrics of
hijab and burkas and kimars and and
and all of that stuff no no no no no
this
is about good old-fashioned colonialism
uh once again i can pick out one
coherent statement there which is
actually true america doesn't have
feelings that has interests
that's exactly right you're right mark
because yeah countries don't have
feelings america's not alone in that
what country do you think has a feeling
tell me tell me a country on earth right
now that has a feeling what are they
feeling right now
yeah countries have interests
um
individual people that make up the
country have feelings
but the country as a whole shouldn't
operate by those feelings it should
operate by interests
those interests are not always purely
uh political or economic those are parts
of the that's that those are interested
as well
but yeah
every country is worried about it's
about its own interests
the problem with america actually is not
that we're motivated by by our interest
but that we're not motivated by our
interests enough
that we were taking we are taking the
interests of other
uh people in other countries
into consideration more than we should
than any other country does
because with most countries
there's there's no controversy they're
worried about their own interests and
the interest in the well-being of their
own people and that is all they are
worried about
and they don't pretend to worry about
anything else
only with us only with america and and
broadly more western countries broadly
is it suddenly
controversial for a country to be
self-interested in that sense
but all the rest of it yes the the burqa
is a tool
[Music]
of of white conservatives
somehow
i was waiting there that's why i played
the whole clip because i'm waiting for
him to try to
draw he has taken a lot of he's strewn a
lot of dots across the table here pretty
haphazardly and i'm waiting for him to
connect them to see what sort of picture
comes together
and uh he doesn't really
but he seems to be trying to argue that
somehow
burkas are a a tool of white
conservative men
to oppress
brown women in afghanistan
either it's a tool of ours or it's a uh
it's a it's a false narrative i don't
maybe he's claiming that they don't it's
not true they don't really have to wear
burqas
oh yeah they're claiming that women
afghanistan don't have agency
yet we claim that because if they show
their their hair in public they'll be
stoned to death
silly me i thought that that was an
attack on the agency of a woman
what you see overall here a lot of these
comparisons um
trying to draw these kinds of
connections
between
you know conservatives and the taliban
we are the american taliban and we've
heard this for years going back 20 years
we've heard this from the left
and this to me raises a couple of
questions
um
the first one is as i asked yesterday
and i'll ask again because i think it's
a good question
why do you want if you're on the left
and you believe that that we have our
own taliban in this country and it's
powerful and numerous
why do you want refugees to come here
in the first place
if you think that this country is
overrun by its own taliban isn't that a
horrible injustice isn't that horribly
unfair to them
i mean
from the the frying pan into the fire
type of thing they escape one taliban
end up at the mercy of another according
to you
let's pretend that you're correct for a
second
yeah we're all in the taliban america is
a systemically racist country very very
oppressive
uh you know we've got law enforcement
officers that are prowling in the
streets
hunting black men murdering them for no
reason
it's such a big problem that they have
to we have riots about it
across the country
why do you want to bring refugees into
this this is not a refuge for them this
is not safe for them
for their own good for their own safety
they should go
into the
into the tolerant and loving arms of
another muslim country in the middle
east
right
is our country a safe haven for
minorities
and oppressed foreigners
and non-white people
who are being oppressed by other
non-white people by the way is it a safe
haven for them or not
if it is a safe haven then you're gonna
have to really drop the oppression
systemic racism american taliban
narrative you're gonna have to pick one
or the other
if it's if it's if it's not a safe haven
and and everything is as bad here as you
say then at the very least we should all
be able to agree that we cannot accept
this whole flood of uh afghan afghan
refugees
we may have different reasons for coming
that to that conclusion but we should be
arriving at the same conclusion
nonetheless
uh and then another question
since we're on the subject
and since the left has
raised
this subject and since they've made this
comparison
i feel i can ask which side is it
exactly
that supports the mass slaughter of
human beings
in this case in the womb
uh the genital mutilation of children
censorship
uh huge restrictions on basic human
freedoms
which side is that
i don't think it's conservatives
so if there is a an analogous situation
here if we have our own version of the
taliban
seems to me
that's the left
so if you're on the left and you're the
one looking for a taliban here in
america i guess what i would say is look
in the mirror
that's where you're gonna find it
in fact pro-abortion leftists
are responsible for for far more
bloodshed
than the taliban
has ever been responsible for
i mean the abortion industry at all the
the abortion industry alone
has killed
kills more people in a year than the
taliban could kill in a decade
you know the taliban looks at planned
parenthood and is there they're jealous
they say teach us your ways o master
how do you guys do it
killing all these baby infidels
so if that's the if you're looking for
the comparison i'm i'm saying i think uh
you may want to look at yourself and
fundamentally there is something in
common here i think
between the american left
and uh and the taliban and
the most fundamental thing in common is
that neither group places any inherent
value on human life
that is why the taliban laughs at our
suggestion
our demand in sternly worded letters
that they respect the rights of women
and minorities and everything else
because there is no concept of human
rights without first a concept of
inherent human worth and dignity if you
don't have inherent human worth and
dignity then there's no human rights
because that's what the idea is founded
on
the reason we have human rights is
because we are people of fundamental
moral worth
created by a loving merciful creator god
and because of that
you know there are certain rights and
liberties that that we have
by our nature
you take the the basis of that away then
you don't have the human rights anymore
that's why the taliban laughs about it
because they don't think and they don't
claim to think
that all people are created equal that
all people have inherent moral worth
they don't believe that
they don't pretend to believe it
the american left they don't believe it
either the only difference is that
sometimes they pretend to believe it
but they clearly don't and you you
couldn't celebrate
the mass slaughter
of a million babies every single year if
you believed in the moral worth
and inherent human dignity of all people
all right let's uh
move on to i guess we'll go now to
reading the comments actually one other
thing
of slightly less importance uh the
washington football team they're now
looking for
their new name and
they've
they've thrown redskins
out the window because that's offensive
for whatever reason and so now they've
they've whittled it down to these names
so they're it's going to be one of these
and they've put the poll out there
they're asking people to vote on it and
they've whittled it down to a list of
eight names and here are the possible
names
the washington armada
the washington brigade
the washington commanders the washington
defenders the washington presidents
the washington red hogs the washington
red wolves
or just the washington football team
which at this point i hope they they
simply go with that the washington
football team
what you see here is first of all
now that we're so worried about
offending people
you're going to end up with the most
boring innocuous names imaginable
because any name that has a little bit
of character to it is going to offend
someone
but then also
so you go from red skins
and that's offensive but you're saying
well we want to we still want to have
something that's red so we'll let's go
with red hogs let's let's go from red
skins to red pigs
is that not only
silly and a terrible name but but i
don't know that also seems offensive to
me
all right let's move now to reading the
comments
uh
joe says yo matt if trump was younger in
2024 would you still prefer desantis
well first of all
i understand it's a hypothetical
question but he's not younger in 2024
and that
and that is that's really the point
now to answer your question yeah i would
still prefer desantis because i think
that he's
a better executive
uh he's better at governing
he's more interested in governing
um
and uh
he's more compelling rhetorically as
well
in front of an audience answering
questions
i think he's he's he's able to string
together
answers and thoughts that to me i think
are more persuasive and compelling than
what you normally get from trump
but we could put all that to the side
like that doesn't even really matter
because the point is that trump will be
78. so even if you disagree with
everything i just said about the
comparison between desantis and trump
that's fine
but he but what we cannot get away from
is that trump will be 78 years old and
we have seen what happens when you elect
a 78 year old president
and you could say all you wanna it's
different with trump no it's not because
trump is a human being
he is a mortal creature
he is subject to the laws of nature just
like any other person is he is not a god
and as you get to that age approaching
your 80s and you're going to turn 80 in
office
you ju you start to significantly lose
your mental faculties and your physical
faculties it happens to everyone it's a
sad thing it's a sad reality but it is a
reality
and so no i there is there is
not any 78 year old in this country who
i would vote to elect not because i have
anything against 78 year old people
or anything like that
i'm a realist and i understand the
realities that come with advanced age
which is also why i wouldn't elect a 22
year old president
nothing against 22 year olds
but there are certain realities that
come with with that age with being that
young
wouldn't want someone like that as
oppressed
uh
shen shaco says please take the dog that
has been there the longest or oldest
you're talking about at the shelter
no way
you want me to take the oldest dog
that's been there the longest at the
animal shelter i think i'm sorry for the
dog but that's not happening i wouldn't
recommend anyone do that there's a
reason the dog has been there that long
that's uh
that's that's another unfortunate
reality that i think we should
deal with
uh jess says matt explaining the proper
way to commit a hate crime on oneself is
spectacular it's like he took the time
to really think this through with which
just shows how devious his mind could
potentially be if he were to use it for
evil instead of good well you give me
too much credit
um
i i i think any any any rational person
if you're going to commit a hate crime
against yourself which probably
probably there's an oxymoron there a
rational person is going to commit a
hate crime against themselves not not a
rational act to begin with
but we could all imagine
more effective ways to do it
where you cover yourself a little bit
more than what we got from this vaccine
official
who mailed herself a
dog muzzle with her own credit card
um
wyder says matt i love your show man but
let's be real here it's never going to
sound very convincing when you're first
explaining how our modern western
civilization believes in things like
human rights and such because it was
uniquely built upon a christian
worldview framework
and a few minutes later you ask why it
should always fall upon us in the modern
civilized west to take in refugees of
war
didn't you did you just answer your own
question before you even asked it
no i don't think i did at all
yeah we are a civilization built on a
christian framework there's no no
question about that
uh were a nation built upon that
which is not to say we're a theocracy
unfortunately as you know if we're up to
me we would be a theocratic fascist
dictatorship
but we are built upon that christian
world view philosophically but we're
still a country
okay and our government
has an obligation
to its own people first
um
being christian does not mean that you
can't have a functioning government
and a functioning government has to has
an obligation has to prioritize its own
people
yeah as a christian in terms of
christian principles you love all people
across the world you love the
downtrodden and all of that of course
and you as an individual christian
you're you're welcome to
pursue that as far as you want to you
can go on a mission trip somewhere you
can go anywhere you want and and help
the poor help the downtrodden it's a
wonderful thing to do
but the government has a responsibility
first and foremost to its own people
i'm not saying that we never take in
have any refugees at all i'm not saying
that
i'm not against the concept
i'm against the way that it is done now
and i don't the problem is i don't trust
our government because they don't
prioritize our own people i don't trust
them to bring in this flood of afghan
refugees many of them men of fighting
age
from a country where
there is
among a certain portion of the
population at the very least
sympathies for the taliban
and i don't trust our government to
bring them in and to vet them properly
and then upon vetting them to make the
right call on the right decision
so that's why
i'm very skeptical of this plan to bring
in all these refugees
uh and teresa says
matt important question have you read
any good books lately yeah i just
finished a book called the last place on
earth about the race to the south pole
in the early 20th century between robert
falcon scott and rolled uh ahmanson
ahmanson is the norwegian he won the
race scott got to the pole uh bef after
behind amundsen
and then scott's whole team died on the
way back
after losing the race and they all die
they freeze to death and starve to death
slowly robinson though the winner was
overshadowed by by scott
because scott became this kind of murder
figure and became a hero in death even
though he was grossly incompetent and he
caused the death of
his entire team because of his
incompetence and then amazon is a
fascinating figure because he was the
first person to navigate the northwest
passage
before being the first to the south pole
and he accomplished that to the south
pole and then he navigated the northeast
passage
um
and that took seven years because he got
stranded in the ice and then he got
attacked by polar bears and it was a
whole thing
and then he was the first to reach the
north pole by plane
and then he went into retirement after
conquering the entire globe
and accomplishing in one lifetime this
thing that entire empires had tried to
do for hundreds of years and had failed
to do
then he goes into retirement in his 50s
he comes out of retirement because
another explorers on an arctic journey
gets trapped in the ice in the in the
arctic
and uh and amazon decides to get in a
plane and try to rescue him
and he crashes into the arc arctic ocean
never seen again so fascinating figure
and most people don't know his name and
this is just another one of those guys
who you go to public school you might
never hear his name mentioned
which is a tragedy so that's the book
pick up that book very interesting
well tragically as much as i love doing
the ads and i love especially telling
you about all the great daily wire
promos i only have one i only have one
today to do this is this is my favorite
part of the day and it's been severely
condensed but if you haven't pulled the
trigger and joined the daily wire then
i'm going to assume you haven't heard of
our reader's pass yet which is a steal
for just four dollars a month the daily
wire readers pass unlocks exclusive
editorial content that unpacks trending
political and cultural topics penned by
everyone from ben shapiro to dan
crenshaw and best of all matt walsh plus
analysis analysis pieces like here's
what went wrong in afghanistan and what
we should have done differently you can
go check that out right now if you have
the reader's pass you can take a deep
dive with readers past collections
different series of articles on a given
subject current collections include a
culture and crisis and blm the
organization behind a movement when you
sign up with readers pass you also get
access to the morning wire newsletter
and a monday through saturday email
covering the top stories that you need
to know available only to daily wire
members it's only four bucks a month so
stop being a cheapskate damn it and go
to uh dailywire.com right now and sign
up for a reader's pass today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our cancellation we must check
in again with our trusty healthcare
workers now i should say that um
i have no ill will towards healthcare
workers at all i respect people in that
line of work i have family members in
that line of work
they're great people and i'm sure
they're not alone in their industry in
that regard
my problem is not with healthcare
workers but with morally deranged
narcissists and attention starved drama
queens there are many people of that
type living in our country today but
events of the last couple of years have
shown a special spotlight on the members
of that group who happen to also wear a
name tag
and scrubs to work so to that end
i have to highlight two men
the first is adam hill md who has an
inexplicably large following on social
media and seems to quite enjoy the
attention he posted this he said hi i'm
a healthcare worker crying at the
hospital it's important to show more of
this
and then there's a selfie of him
with a single tear rolling down his
cheek
now we've already spent enough time
arguably a lot more than enough time
discussing the issue of men crying as
you know there are only six acceptable
reasons for a man to cry does this fall
into one of those categories maybe you
know i don't know what he just
experienced maybe something really
traumatic happened to him it's quite
possible the issue of course
is that he took out his phone
and documented it and pushed it posted
it to social media
how does that work exactly i mean think
about any time when you were sincerely
distraught over something a time when
you were suffering emotionally a time
when life saddled you with a burden that
was too heavy to carry maybe a loved one
died maybe they ran out of guacamole at
chipotle whatever the case may be would
it have ever occurred to you as you were
crying
to pull out your phone and take a
picture of the event
have you ever said to yourself my god
i'm so upset this is terrible i'm
devastated you know what this would make
a great selfie let me get my phone
has anything like that ever crossed your
mind
it would seem that if it did you
couldn't really have been all that upset
to begin with no person who is really
sad who is really grieving
actually wants their grief to be
recorded and displayed for public
consumption
no person except for alexandria queso
cortez of course who
as we know was experiencing very real
trauma at the site of an empty parking
lot in texas and brought a professional
photographer along to record her
profoundly sincere emotional breakdown
but other than that
this is just not a normal thing
here's what it comes down to you know
your suffering becomes trivial and
meaningless
when you use it for attention and pity
i'm not the one saying that your
suffering is trivial you are saying that
you're communicating that
when you seek to cash it in for retweets
you have chosen to trivialize it you
have made it into mere content
and that was your choice
i can't take your suffering seriously
because you don't take it seriously
clearly
so so much for adam hill md now for uh
dr jason valentine in alabama the
washington post has this story it says
in alabama where the nation's lowest
vaccination rate has helped push the
state closer to a record number of
hospitalizations a physician has sent a
clear message to his patients
don't come in for medical treatment if
you are unvaccinated jason valentine a
physician at diagnostic and medical
clinic infirmary health and mobile
mobile alabama uh mobile mobile alabama
posted a photo on facebook this week of
him pointing to a sign taped to a door
informing patients of his new policy
coming october 1st the sign reads dr
valentine will no longer see patients
that are not vaccinated against cover
19.
valentine wrote in the post which has
since been made private but was captured
in online images that there were no
conspiracy theories no excuses stopping
anyone from being being vaccinated the
doctor who said at least three
unvaccinated patients have asked him
where they could get a vaccine since he
posted the photo
has remained resolute to those who have
questioned his decision in recent days
okay now i have to wonder how many
divorces this guy has
given that vows apparently mean nothing
to him
doctors may not may not take the
traditional hippocratic oath anymore
but they do swear to treat the sick and
to do no harm i mean this is the promise
doctors make to the public simply by
calling themselves doctors
it is implied
a doctor who refuses to treat sick
people is like a garbage man who refuses
to touch your garbage can if you put
trash in it
i'm not touching that thing what'd you
put in there trash
he is fundamentally refusing to do the
one single thing that his job requires
him to do
now the scary thing of course is that
he's not the only one who thinks that uh
unvaccinated people are unworthy of
medical treatment you hear this argument
a lot actually the justification is that
unvaccinated people aren't taking care
of their health and don't deserve to be
treated when they suffer the
consequences of their own reckless
decisions as the argument goes also
again as the argument goes
unvaccinated people are a strain on the
health care system
but even if i were to agree with the
framing here which i don't
shouldn't we apply this principle
consistently
obesity kills far more people than covet
does
and it even helps to kill many of the
people who die of covid
so why aren't we refusing medical
treatment to fat people who eat fast
food and haven't seen the inside of a
gym since the clinton administration
they're behaving recklessly they're not
taking care of their health they're not
taking the vaccine as it were the
vaccine here being broccoli and sit-ups
they're also a strain on the health care
system
obesity costs us billions of dollars a
year and i'm not just talking about our
tab at cinnabun
and it's not just obesity what about
people who get stds
most stds are contracted through
reckless and avoidable behavior what
about alcoholics with liver damage or
smokers with lung cancer
as it turns out a huge number of the
medical problems from mild to severe and
everything in between which send people
to doctoral doctors offices and
hospitals have a lifestyle component to
them
if doctors weren't going to treat people
whose choices have contributed to their
ailments then they're not going to be
treating almost anybody
as it turns out as a doctor
it is your job to treat the sick no
matter how they got sick
if you aren't prepared to do that job or
if you require constant pity and
admiration from the public in order to
do it
perhaps you should find another line of
work go work at starbucks or something
they actually from what i understand
will promote you if you cry on the job
over there
so try that instead
but for now
these particular healthcare workers
and the rest like them are of course
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
chairman of the joint chiefs mark milley
admits that the biden administration
has no idea what's going on in
afghanistan a major new study suggests
that the covid lockdowns made babies
significantly dumber and the world
economic forum promises to shoot laser
beams into your heart check it out on
the michael knowles show
[Music]